for many of us Fitness comes in Seasons
you have your Summers when things are
going great you're in the best shape of
your life you're hitting PRS diet is
dialed in you're looking great feeling
great but then comes the
Autumn then comes the fall but this is
normal maintaining optimal Fitness isn't
possible for most people it's
unsustainable what's important is how we
pick ourselves back up for me it
happened recently I was in great shape I
was feeling really good my calisthenic
skills were improving and my physique
was one of the best it's been in recent
memory but I decided to take a break a
little while back um I was having a weak
vacation visiting my family in bouran I
think it's important when you do this
sort of thing that you can take a
planned break from your training you
know I think if you aren't able to step
away from your training for even a week
then maybe your training's reached a
point where it's not healthy anymore you
know maybe you're not in control anymore
what I wasn't banking on was coming back
and injuring my elbow I was going for a
walk it was a bit cold and I saw this
calisthenics Park and stupidly I thought
it'd be okay to attempt to Muscle Up
from cold something went pop and well
the rest history Alba's been bothering
me ever since I was managing to scrape
by you know I was still able to train a
little bit but it was also a busy time
for us at that point busy with work for
me but also my daughter was starting her
new school and that meant a lot of prep
work and things and I mean emotionally
it was quite a big deal for me you know
mingling with all these other children
it was inevitable really but my daughter
brought home a sickness bug and we all
started vomiting profusely first it was
my daughter of course I had to be a bit
more available to help around the house
but then it was my wife which of course
meant she wasn't able to look after the
children which meant I needed to take
time off work there are things that are
more important you know than being able
to do a handstand pushup or not that
meant waking up early getting my
daughter to school then looking after my
one-year-old son all day the only chance
I had to work was during his nap and at
night time when he was in
bed unfortunately my son is going
through something called a sleep
regression at the moment I'm sure any
parents listening to probably coming out
in a pavlovian fear response right now
that and he's teething and the result is
he's waking up in the middle of the
night and not going back to sleep so so
some nights I was working till about
1:00 in the morning and then I was
waking up at 3:00 in the morning or 4:
in the morning and he wasn't going back
to
sleep and then I got sick I was vomiting
profusely for 24 hours after that I
wasn't able to really train or eat
properly and I don't know if it's an age
thing but lately every time I get sick I
have some kind of lack to intolerance
that lasts for about a month or two so
way protein was out of the question as
you can imagine it led to loss of
strength weight loss loss of energy loss
of motivation but like I said this is
totally normal and what's really
important is how you get back up it
doesn't matter how hard you train how
knowledgeable you are or how good your
training program is if you can't stick
to your training then you're not going
to get any results so we could say that
creating a training program that you're
actually going to stick to is the number
one most important thing you can think
about when designing a program in the
first place this is something that I
think actually eludes a lot of people
who have these lofty goals these ideas
of what they want to achieve but they
don't think that realistically about how
they're actually going to achieve them
and how they're going to fit them into
their routine first up I think it's
really important to Cave at this by
saying if you ever need to take time off
your training it's important that you
feel able to do that if you want to have
a healthy relationship with your
training then you should be in control
not your training so whether you just
want time off whether you're feeling
sick or whether life has gotten in the
way it is important to be able to
sometimes say I'm not going to train
this week that's normal and the
influencers who have a go at people for
taking time off are really maybe a bit
too obsessive perhaps a little bit
detached from reality life's going to
happen sometimes you're not going to be
able to train the way you want to be
able to but what's important is that you
don't give up entirely I made a video a
while back saying you can and should
train every single day and whilst that
could have been a little bit of a
clickbaity title if you watch the video
my point was that you shouldn't be
training hard every single day but you
should be moving every single day you
should be incorporating some form of
movement some stuff that you could
consider to be training into your
everyday routine and I stand by this I
think it's important and at the same
time if this break is dragging on for
weeks and weeks maybe your house flooded
and you've had to move into a hotel or
your in-law's house or something then
you need to be able to adapt your
training you need to be able to do the
next best thing until you can get back
to your workout program proper in other
words you don't need to think about it
as training or not training you need to
think about it as how you going to do
the best training you can in the given
situation so you can still have your
ambitious and your elaborate training
program you should also have contingency
plans for when you're not able to do
that and keep in mind that for many
people the slightly paired down version
of what you're going to do is going to
be what you're doing most of the time
and there's nothing wrong with that what
you want to get here is the maximum bang
for your buck people are getting great
results training twice a week three
times a week and training with fewer
lifts and less time and if you can do
that if it means that you're then going
to actually stick to your training
you're going to get much much better
results in the long term so if you can
find a program that works for you and is
minimal then that's much better and so
this is my first tip for training in a
way that is highly sustainable and
that's to create a minimum version of
your workout and a maximum version of
your workout so you can have this one
and a half hour Mega session if
everything is going perfectly to plan
where you're doing all of those
accessory lifts doing all of those weird
movements balance training whatever else
you can also have a really short and
sharp 20-minute workout for when you
just need to get in get results and get
out because those times are going to
happen so when I'm training I write out
my program and then I highlight the
things that are essential the things
that I absolutely must not miss or I'll
put them at the start of my workout in
the list so that the things down the
bottom if I don't get to them as often
it's not the end of the world they're
the nice to haves but the stuff at the
top I definitely do there you've got
your consistency and down the bottom
you've got your variation and your
interesting stuff in a similar vein
something I've talked about in the past
is creating workouts that you can do in
different places so different versions
of the same workout so say you're doing
a push pull leg split you might have
your push workout your pull workout and
your legs workout now what I like to do
is have a version of each of those for
the gym for my office cuz as you can see
I've got a bunch of training equipment
here I'm very lucky in that regard for
my home for Fields so I want to be able
to go to a field and do a similar push
workout as I would do if I was at the
gym so if I'm at the gym maybe I'm doing
bench press maybe I'm doing military
press but if I'm in a field maybe I'm
doing push-ups Maybe I'm doing dips
maybe I'm doing Pike push-ups that kind
of thing so as you can see I've got
different versions for different
scenarios and sure they're not going to
be perfectly analogous a bench press is
a much heavier movement than push-ups
but if it's that or nothing then
push-ups will cut it in fact doing
push-ups should just ensure that your
pecs your strength ticks over for a
short time if you're forced to miss the
bench for a week this is my issue
unfortunately with a lot of powerlifting
movements is they're just not very
accessible for a lot of people if you
don't have access to a power rack and
you don't have a 100 plus kilog of
weight kicking around then it's hard for
some people to do them that's why having
nice Alternatives works really well for
me personally of course having the right
equipment can make a big difference here
there are certain items that I possess
that are really useful for when I want
to get a quick workout in so for example
my dip bars they get so much use I love
my dip bars you can stack them really
neatly they stack next to each other and
take up very little space most people
can still get a pretty good stimulus on
their pecs their triceps their shoulders
even at a more advanced level by doing a
set of 30 dips and if you're thinking 30
that's outside the hypertrophy zone or
the strength zone or whatever just give
it a go and I think you'll find that you
can really get some size by doing this
because you're flooding those muscles
with blood you're getting to that point
of failure at which point the body
starts to recruit the faster twitch of
muscle fibers which it didn't need
before but now they're only available
and if you're using them as a carry over
to replace your bench press then it's a
little bit more challenging at least
than push-ups likewise a kettle bell I
find fantastic because there's not a lot
of easy ways that you can train the hip
hinge I think kettlebell swings are
wonderful for that you can also practice
things like snatches and cleans things
that you can't easily do with with
dumbbells and they're fantastic as a
form of metabolic conditioning when it
comes to cardio one of my favorite tools
comes from today's sponsor cross rope
and that's ropeless jump ropes so if
that sounds a bit like a contradiction
in terms what you're going to do is take
your cross rope and then you're going to
detach the rope from the handle and
fortunately cross rope makes it very
easy to do that then what you're going
to do is you're going to take your
little widget here and you're going to
attach that
instead then what you've got is a slight
weight as but also that nice swinging
motion to make sure you're doing the
right thing with your hands and if you
attach these to their handles which are
their smart handles it'll even do things
like count the number of jumps you've
done and help to guide you through
workout so yeah if you're in the living
room you can't easily do jump rope
because you're going to you know damage
the ceiling but if you have these then
you can do a little bit of jump rope
anywhere just gives you that little bit
of feedback allows you to track your
jumps and things like that and it also
adds that little bit of extra weight
that cross rope do so well meaning you
get a slightly more full body workout
you're still getting all those nice
additional benefits like lightness of
foot and ankle stiffness for more
explosive athleticism and viewers of the
bioner can get 15% off by using code
bioner at checkout check out the link in
the description down below and thanks
again to cross R for sponsoring this
video now I'm with the show and finally
I'll once again cover the idea of
training in multiple smaller bursts
having modular workouts split throughout
the day I personally find this as an
easier way to train it's much easier for
me to get two sets of 20 minutes rather
than one set of 40 minutes and this is
another reason why I like to have
modular workouts that I can either
combine into a single workout or break
up into multiple smaller workouts this
way if I do have a push day then I Can
Do shoulders in the morning and I can do
pecs in the afternoon something like
that this works better with my routine
and if you keep it to around 15 minutes
you don't get all that sweaty and
splashing underneath a sink there
probably going to be enough yes you need
to warm up I made a video on warming up
you can do that in about 5 minutes and
you can go for a walk if you want to
cool down or another great one is just
to break off your Mobility and do that
throughout the day this is something
else I've discussed plenty and this
isn't a compromise this actually could
lead to Greater gains because by
splitting my workouts up I give myself
much more time to recover before moving
on to the next bunch of exercises for
example if I am doing pecs and then
shoulders I'm going to do the pecs first
and then four hours later Do shoulders
I'll be much fresher going into the
shoulder workout able to lift more and
put in more energy likewise you're
spiking protein synthesis multiple times
throughout the day and I just think it's
a slightly more natural and normal way
to train you're telling your body I move
a lot I lift a lot you're not someone
who's just static all the time except
for maybe an hour three times a week I
think there's a big difference there
when you split your training up into
small pieces when you recognize that
sometimes it's okay to pair back your
training you can take this even further
and start doing mini workouts that are
just entirely designed around being as
easy and as convenient as possible and
it's not just about time it's not only
about being able to fit in a workout
that's effective in 5 to 10 minutes
what's also really important is being
able to train when you're low on
motivation low on energy and also when
you kind of want to be doing something
else because sometimes I find life so
busy I get no opportunity to watch any
TV to play any computer games so that's
another scenario where training can be
more difficult but again there are ways
around this I made a video recently
about some gentle Mobility you can do
things like getting into a gentle deep
Squat and just moving around in that
position rather than being in a grueling
stretch position and holding it for
minutes on end so when I'm feeling low
motivation when I'm very tired or ill or
whatever just getting into a gentle
squat like this just getting into gentle
positions moving around in that position
this can be much more palatable and
sometimes you'll find that doing that
then gives you a bit more energy a bit
more motivation to do something a little
bit bigger if it is something like time
and maybe stress that's getting in the
way if you just want a really quick
simple workout then you can do something
as simple as five lots of 10 pull-ups
give yourself a little bit of break in
between that's a really short and sharp
pull workout which sure it's not
particularly well-rounded well balanced
but if that's all you've got time for if
that's all you can bring yourself to
think about then it's absolutely great
just training on on one piece of
equipment one station or even one
exercise that's just a really good way
to remove any of the mental hurdles if
you know you're just going in there
standing in one place and doing one
exercise that's a great way to convince
yourself to give it a go but finally
something I've been talking about on my
blog a little bit is that sometimes it's
worth doing a distracted workout so we
hear all the time from Fitness YouTubers
that you know you should be focusing
100% on your workout if you're answering
texts or listening to a podcast whilst
you train then you're not focused you're
not creating the maximum mind muscle
connection and you're not getting the
most results that you can get and that's
probably true but in reality this is
like a 2% benefit or maybe even less
than that you're not going to really
notice it so maybe ideally you would
have a really strict disciplined workout
where you put in 100% effort and then
just sit staring into space angr in
between your sets but if it's between
not working out at all or working out
where you allow yourself to browse the
internet a little bit between your sets
well then I know what I think is
probably preferable another example
might be to get those ropeless jump
ropes and just do some jump rope whilst
watching a movie or something just for
10 minutes it's not much but it's
certainly better than nothing and if
that's all you can motivate yourself to
do if that's how you're going to get
back on the horse starting with these
easy gentle movements back towards
regular and more intense exercise well
then it's certainly better than nothing
I'll even sometimes play computer games
in my rest times sure it's not optimal
but actually that can be quite
motivating if it's a game like Devil May
Cry of course the ideal scenario is that
you find your training itself enjoyable
and inherently motivating I love hand
balancing so I could just quite happily
spend an hour practicing handstands and
never get bored it doesn't have to be
this All or Nothing thing so I'm giving
you permission to do halfast workouts if
it means that you actually do them and
especially if you're recovering from an
injury or an illness if you're tired if
you're very stressed we need to be a bit
kind to ourselves and you know it's not
competition Fitness is a marathon not a
Sprint so there you have it guys that's
how I recommend building workouts that
are extremely versatile and adaptable
and that you can do anywhere this is how
I stay active even when life is getting
a bit more challenging I hope you found
something useful there and let me know
in the comments down below how you train
in a way that's adaptable if you would
like a training program that is focused
on functional training on combining
different skills and modalities and that
has modular options so you can break up
throughout the day then check out my
ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 that comes with
over 2 hours of instructional footage
and an 80 plus page ebook I'll leave a
link down below either way thank you so
much for watching this one guys and I'll
see you next
time bye for
now